oi oi
[Música]
tudo bem Pode me apresentar eu quero
dizer que eu sou uma pessoa que acredita
na mudança e no potencial dos processos
de transformação então se você assim
como eu senti atração uma vontade de
sair por aí transformando tudo se você
se sente impotente diante daquilo que
você não pode transformar se você
acredita que importante é de um carro
melhor mais justo mais igualitário
porque você acredita que a gente
continuar evoluindo e se tornar uma
versão melhor de nós mesmos pais
diferença
é você que tá falando
Olá meu nome é Carolina Damião
de por contadores de história muita
coisa eu já delas teatro diretório
trabalha com mobilizadora numa
distribuidora de filmes desafios e
criação encerro jovem de Publicidade eu
escrevo peças teatrais canções
transparentes estou ensaiando escrever
um roteiro
e eu estou passando ultimamente por um
processo bem profunda e
ainda pediu para falar seguinte frase
minha mãe sabe do que eu tô falando eu
preciso falar sobre essa capa pelo seu
mastiga da Maternidade Eu sempre me
incomodei muito com os potenciais que
não se realizam por pensar em algo
alguém esse potencial se realiza que tem
gente muda
desculpa muito essa calça tem gente que
não muda
em
vista a gente tá dando abertura tá
mudando essa conta pra gente
e Eu agora estou me transformando em um
ano aí você pode me dizer mas Carol o
seu filho já tem quase um ano é que é um
processo de transformação não é um passe
de mágica
é como se já tivesse as asas formadas o
corpo praticamente quase todo fora do
caso aqui eu ainda não entendo como uma
lagarta
e eu me olho me seguir eu vejo a tudo
ali sou eu é uma mãe
Marisa meu
cabelo Amil
e aqui eu não me reconheço como se não
conseguisse chegar nada porque eu
conhecia nem sempre parecida comigo
ultimamente
e e
em casa não pode ser Mercúrio está
retrógrado pode Setembro 11 meses você
acha que é mais do que isso a sensação
que eu tenho é que tudo o que achava
interessante em mim morreu
Oi e essa é uma parte dos processos de
transformação de que as me fala da qual
as pessoas fogem
Esse é o princípio dos processos de
informação né E aí depois que você achou
bolo consegue recuperar a farinha eu
sinto uma pessoa te guardei a farinha
sabe para fazer um bolo especial numa
ocasião especial eu sempre deixei a
farinha vencer eu fiz dia farinha eu
nunca comi bolo para ficar mexendo
porque eu sempre fico muito medo não
consegui retornar eu não consegui
encontrar aquilo que eu conhecia Quem
nunca desistiu de algo por medo de
iniciar uma caminhada depois ela não
conseguiu se reencontrar por medo de se
perder no caminho por medo de não se
reconhecer que você salta de paraquedas
não tem como você voltar pro avião em
pleno voo e mesmo depois nada mais é seu
mesmo e você nem vem então Limpo
e a dor dos processos de transformação é
uma dos Saudosa porque dói a gente
seguir sem carregar pelo que a gente tá
conheci o corpo ele já tá acostumado
coração da gente tá pegado a Cabeça Ela
já sabe calcular os prós e os contras
rapidamente é tipo uma zona de conforto
também Essa zona de reconhecimento
porque é difícil e é desafio é boa a
gente se permite mudar porque é
desafiador a gente está em constante
aprendizado da gente mesmo que haja
transformação a gente precisa de
abertura para poder de avaliar até mesmo
pra gente poder abandonar muitas vezes é
preciso abandonar ideias formadas
concebidos por que tá que haja
transformação a gente precisa tá pronta
a
gente precisa de entrega e passem
entrega a gente precisa muito fortemente
disponível o novo
Oi e eu vou chegar você vai concordar
comigo eu tenho quase certeza que
tesouros cavalos-marinhos soluções não
são coisas que a gente encontra na
superfície das coisas a gente precisa
mergulhar
mergulho é um outro sinônimo de
maternidade mergulhar o verbo
intransitivo pronominal é afundar-se
inteiramente em
e antes de mãe olhava no espelho
Eu não conhecia a senhora era como se
estivesse uma sensação de saber
exatamente no já estava avisando uma
frase já é
já fez a mudança que você quer ver no
mundo que hoje quando me olho no espelho
o que eu vejo uma mudança
fica difícil para mim compreender a
mudança alugar sou eu
e antes de ser mãe melhor agradecer e
reconhecer quem lá mas hoje quando a
melhor no espelho e veja mudam muito
difícil compreender que a mudança porque
é bem interessante a gente pensar se tem
como as fugidas processo de
transformação nem como a gente ignorar a
gente driblar eles vão acontecendo o
próprio tempo ele é transformative à
medida que a gente vai carregando coisa
do nosso passado essa carga ela cuble
nosso presente ela vai interferir
diretamente no nosso futuro a gente os
cargos transferência nova Renovada
fresca do nosso presente a gente tá
assim fazendo com que o nosso futuro
seja menos do que ele poderia ser
e eu tenho certeza que você conhece
alguém que tem uma vivência diferente
então o resultado diferente na vida mas
essa pessoa não percebe primeiro precisa
vivenciar um processo de transformação
então exemplo bem banal se é assim você
quer tocar violão por exemplo
habilidade nova competência mais a
pessoa se treinar violão a pessoa que
toca com alguma frequência o que importa
é muito diferente da pessoa que você é
hoje porque as experiências nos
transformam a maneira como a gente corre
o tempo
elas não falam
e tem algumas tem o processo de
transformação frente adquirir passar por
eles né Tem um novo resultado aí a gente
pode planejar a gente pode definir
objetivos traçar metas até mesmo que eu
tomo B só tem outros que eles estavam
assim ó feridos
é só que tango a gente precisa de
abertura disponibilidade permissão para
que eles aconteçam porque é muito
desgastante a gente não tá criar um
processo de transformação não tem como
eles vão acontecer o estão acontecendo E
aí quando a gente vê alguém cantando
fazer essa luta a gente tem essa
situação sem produtivo mesmo que não vai
levar nada porque esta infecção incômoda
que a gente tem das pessoas
insistem no passado os potenciais
enxerga tão grande mas que a gente vê
que você venha mesmo
e eu não tenho muito conta na verdade eu
gostei bastante
bastante a Carol que eu conhecia
sabe chorei bastante
dói uma dor profunda a gente vê caixinha
aqui
e também é muito incrível a gente fica
mente brotar a maternidade é um Vencedor
ela vai descarregar tudo que a gente não
precisa utilizar para geração de
potência ela acontece
e o que que é sobra o sobra nada porque
todas as obras que foram paradas
vestidas a pergunta é oxidável
eu lembro um conto do dízimo passar o
francesa muito bom mas eu gosto muito de
sol e como se chama o Horla nesse conto
ele fala de um personagem que um dia se
olhou no espelho e ele viu todo o
ambiente ao redor dele refletido só que
ele não conseguiu se enxergar
obrigado como é que tá tudo fica
repetindo mas a imagem dele não chegava
sim alguma coisa entre ele e você me
pedindo a imagem sempre chegar né essa
luz refletida e aí ele
sensação Ele percebeu então que ele tava
vem logo por causa que ele não conseguia
enxergar iluminou a presença de mas ele
chamou isso
porque foi o nome que ele encontrou para
não ficar de vela
precisa dela é um novo possível que a
gente precisa sim para cá para poder
enxergar
o assunto chato eu aprendi o público ele
vai se interessar por aquilo que nós a
todos os Interessante sua ator em cena
ele se interessa por um sapato o público
volta o seu interesse por esse sapato se
ele se interessa por uma flor o público
voltas interesse que uma força interesse
Genuíno o público percorre-se interesse
porque em cena o interesse preciso está
no momento presente tá com a peça seja
um acontecimento
eu aprendi com o teatro que a história
ela se faz a ser contada é viva não tem
nada que aconteceu nada que vai
acontecer tudo está acontecendo o que
interessa para nós atores e tem um
público cativo participativo de uma obra
teatral aquilo que acontece no momento
presente
das situações se transforma em
a maternidade
entrou entre mim e o espelho e ela
arrancou a imagem que eu conhecer mim e
ela me trouxe uma novidade um pouco para
mim
e ela me fez ver aqui na vida assim como
cena interesse em casa momento presente
aqui a existência seja um acontecimento
porque a vida que transforma a
vida é o que está acontecendo os
processos de transformação esse poder
arrancadas e descarregar tudo o que a
gente não vai utilizar para geração de
potência
e olha morcego
um pouco do que isso para ver hein mãe
que era mais ou
também todas as outras possibilidades e
potências que emergiram
agora eu preciso conhecer interessar
O que é preciso interessar novidades e
o final o bolo está assado
o que a gente saiba se deliciar
toda a ideia precisa ser gestado o que o
chão
o que precisa de nós para ser criado
em casa